you know as a father year-year duties
are to naturally love and protect your
children that's that's what your
appearing for and you know the the job
of the emergency services it's a look up
there in cases an emergency and that was
an emergency and the frustrating bit is
I get all these people coming up to me
saying to me what can we learn from this
and that's a really wrong thing to say
because terrorism is nothing new without
the huge wake-up call of 911 Paris the
year before was constantly getting
attacked Britain has what about someone
who maybe this was one man Obama goes in
kills your daughter many other people
names dozens more is he not responsible
for this I get this question asked quite
a lot how'd you feel towards he murdered
my daughter how did you want me to what
you want me to say he's a merger as a
criminal as many others you know it's if
if you've lost the loved one through you
know a terrorist or a somebody shooting
each other you know it's all he's a
murderer so okay you know what one more
job to say if you again I suppose some
of the media want me to say you know do
I blame him or do I for me looking so
far I put the blame on mi5 and our
government for this because the near
about him thinking about him a long time
ago and they didn't look into him and
this guy went on YouTube to find out how
to create a bomb he went to Libya and
came back after a couple of days and
when he's under the watchful eye of mi5
which is the world's most intelligence
services and their job is to protect the
country after so many terrorist attacks
and on top of all that the movements
that he had rolling up to that attack
and going to prison and visiting
preachers of Islam and and not picking
up on all these things for me what else
do you want from him she wanted to give
you a call in the morning
and tell you what and through all these
reports that we've seen so far
you know there is blame on them which is
why it's so important to start this
inquest so we can get these answers
because what can we learn from this I'm
sorry I've lost me eight-year-old
daughter I am not brushing my daughter
under the carpet for you to come and say
to me what can we learn from this
enough enough enough is enough you know
she's she's young child that needs to be
here you know and it's it's wrong